foreign
let's go to uh Christine in San Antonio
home of the Alamo and PeeWee Herman's
bike in the basement what's up Christine
hey Dr D how are you partying man what
are you up to
I am in crisis management mode but I am
okay oh man I got you I don't know if I
got you or nothing I just like to
declare that you do that's why I'm
calling so what's up what's up
uh first of all I just wanted to tell
you thank you for doing the Lord's work
I do miss your horse noises um we
unfortunately missed you in San Antonio
and your Christmas edition of your
questions for humans yeah so hopefully
we'll get to do both soon I know I I saw
it and I meant to order it and then I I
waited for the Black Friday sale they
were all gone so I think there's a deck
over there on the customer service
counter if it's there Jenna will get it
and mail it to you okay
you'll get it after Christmas
but if they're sold out if they're sold
out they're gone already
good gosh okay never mind they're sold
out they're just they're they're nodding
that's all right
I appreciate it all right hopefully we
get to see you next time you're in the
area so awesome I got an event I got an
event coming up in Austin in a few weeks
uh maybe y'all can come up uh then
yeah yeah we'll definitely try to make
that happen
um so my old question was and if you
give me I'm sorry I have it written down
two minutes I will get through this
Spiel and then I'm all yours all right
spill it up
thank you my old question was in my
situation does love look like sending a
Christmas card or not however things
have changed my younger sister went off
the charts she's breaking ceilings and
all the wrong kinds of way our family
values growing up did not reflect this
Behavior a few months ago she blindsided
our family and acted erratically left
her own home and lived with friends that
no one knew she had she's found to be
using drugs then last night she reaches
out and asks us for help so my new
questions are
what kind of mental health professional
can I reach out that can give her the
help she needs someone who can actually
determine facts from fiction as she is a
very convincing liar and could be hiding
truce out of fear of repercussions from
the people she's staying with two is
there a way to get a mandatory mental
health evaluation possibly while a
medical exam is being conducted is that
something medical professionals can
enforce because we've tried to get
assistance from local PD from multiple
occasions and we've been met every time
with a lot of resistance and no help
um
and then overall if you have any other
recommendations we I'm an open book uh
the situation my sister cut off the
family she became involved in suspected
criminal activity started using meth a
few months ago she made it painfully
clear that she wants nothing to do with
any biological family or lifetime
friends she recently recently gave a
permanent custody of her son it was a
fight to protect him but we did it when
it comes to her she's an adult who's
very sick and needs help but the law is
not helping us at all
I'm done always respect you so first I
just want to say um
I'm sorry so I can tell that you love
your sister
and Christmas is gonna have a big hole
in it this year
yeah it's been
and she's probably going in the family
who's helping I'm the emergency
management manager
who gave you that role
I was put in that role
the parents really fall into it
everybody listens to me okay
I I would say I rise to the occasion
because that's I would suggest you
resign your position immediately
okay
um
the first thing out of the gate I want
you to really work on
and this might be writing a letter to
your sister that you're never gonna send
this might be your 12 year old
self-writing a letter to your 10 year
old sister however old age differences
between the two of you
but there won't be any healing until you
switch off
your judgment switch
and you switch on your I'm with you
switch
okay okay everything in your letter from
about I mean not from your letter from
what you just read
everything from this isn't the family
values that she knows and she's doing
this and she's doing this and I'm trying
to do this
says it's from a position of
she's a puppy who keeps peeing in the
floor and I don't know how to get her to
stop and I'm her owner and I understand
how somebody who is mapped out of their
mind and they're abandoning their family
and their children it feels like like it
feels like the pipes just burst in the
house
but if you bring that chaotic energy to
somebody who's struggling with addiction
like this
that that energy is jet fuel for
the problematic behaviors
and there's a lot of there's a lot of
research about it and it gets a lot of
bad press
um
but healing from addiction healing from
drug use Almost Never
comes from a like upping the aggression
ante
okay
that's number one so I want you to
take off any sort of superiority maybe
begin to ask yourself the question what
in bloody hell happened in her life
things you know about things you may not
know about
that this is how she's got to get
through her day
okay what in the world happened
and my guess is you probably know some
of it and my guess is there may be a
couple things that
your eyes would pop out of your head if
you heard
yeah either or right all that to say is
it just changes the posture
to get your butt in here to
I really love it if you came home that's
two different propositions right so
that's number one number two I wanna I
know you're right in the middle of it
and this is hard I want to back out and
respect what the police officers are
doing even though it's super frustrating
the whole our entire system is based on
not taking away somebody's civil rights
and so the threshold to look at another
adult and say you have lost the
privilege of a of being in control of
your own life that's the premise of this
country however screwed up we've gotten
it and I make no mistake about that
we've screwed that up for years and
years and years but that's one of the
foundational premises and so to get a
government agency to take away agency
from another adult is very very hard
that bar is very high and usually it's
harm to self or others
and there is a pretty significant
bifurcation between mental health if you
have schizophrenia versus you're an
addict
our approach to Addiction in this
country is still very punitive you are
breaking the rules
versus you're sick with a disease
yeah see what I'm saying and so if your
sister had schizophrenia
um or you might have a better chance of
getting medical power of attorney over
her or having her some sort of um
involuntary Commitment if she was uh you
know
experiencing suicidal ideation or
anything like that having a sister is
doing math it's gonna be very very hard
outside of she gets busted with meth and
she goes to jail and has to clean up
there
Yeah we actually tried that and um the
police were not helpful at all we're
just trying to get a removed from
the environment that she's choosing to
be chose homelessness for the last 48
hours
um completely hungry and starving and
frantic and why is she why is she making
that choice is it because she's crazy is
she still high she's still she's still
not in her right mind
I suspect she's not in her right mind
and we called police and I officially
requested a medical eval on site and
they just said well there's not enough
uh indicators here in your shitty family
for not helping her like taking her in
and stuff so
what what does it look like if you do
bring her home
um will she come home okay I know I
mean so she won't stab me or something
like that what in your world has have
given you inclination that she is
violent
uh she
ikh and she's already made a false
false with my brother for beating her
and our family for beating her when
nobody has that discharge has obviously
got dropped
um but I just can't trust her in my own
home because she's happy to create false
CPS reports police reports you name it
okay
[Music]
um
and the few times this situation has
happened in my life not with family
members but with people who I love close
enough that I consider them family
um
I have resorted to two things and it's
very very difficult number one writing a
letter
and the reason I write a letter so they
can hold on to it
and it has amazed me how people have
hung on to those things when they
literally hang on to nothing else to
hang on to these and the letter starts
with I love you and I miss you that's
how the letter starts yeah
and
when you're ready
I'll be here
yeah and that the second thing is is you
got to open your hands and let go
because she is clearly communicating I'm
an adult and I do not want you in my
life
unless it's convenient
yeah exactly
and so if she's holding something that
says when you are ready
because helping somebody who is abusing
drugs helping somebody who's struggling
with alcohol and takes somebody who's
struggling with any number of things
is right and good and hard and those
people don't have a right to be abusive
to you
right so it's easy for the cops to
whatever police officer said well you're
just scumbag family for not taking them
in yeah she doesn't have a right to come
to your house and verbally harass you or
to make fake reports or to beat you all
up or anything like that
so when she's ready it might be that you
will pay the first week of or you will
get with the family and the y'all will
have the funds to make sure she can go
to rehab because that's where she's her
first Stop's got to be at a 30-day
inpatient treatment facility
yeah we're doing that right now
um I've got some treatment facilities
lined up and I'm hoping I can convince
her I mean obviously I can't talk her
into going if she doesn't want to go but
I'm going to present the options and if
she says yes take her there yeah I'll
drop you off
yep and I'll be the first one picking
you up cheering you when when um
I'm allowed to but I can't make you do
this
I can't I can't I'm not your parent I'm
just someone who loves you and it's
killing me to watch what's happening who
got custody of of of her child
uh my parents okay
um
I'm sorry
me too
yeah I'm gonna tell you one more thing
that um is also hard to hear
you're also still allowed to enjoy your
Christmas
yeah
and every time you smile or laugh or put
joy in the world or over tip a waiter or
a waitress at some restaurant
you're injecting Beauty into the world
you're not taking you're not violating
something you're not ruining something
you know what I mean
mm-hmm
and so I would appreciate that I would
do the best I could to laugh as much as
I can as hard as it's going to be to
ghosts over serve and over give and have
fun with my kids I would try my best as
hard as it's going to be
because the alternative is is she's
having a miserable Christmas holiday
because she's hurting so badly and she's
making some tough tough dangerous scary
bad choices
and
I guess I'm just going to choose to be
miserable too see how that didn't help
anything
no and we've been as a family this has
been a shared family Trauma from the
start we've been very intentional about
still celebrating our ups and downs
there's been a lot to celebrate it's
just with a lot of you know it's a
roller coaster yeah
um
I would if I was you to go back to my
original thing I would resign my
position as the family
um crisis responder
it's not your job it's your Mom and
Dad's job
and if they choose to not do that cool
I'll choose to be a sister
but I'm not going to be the person that
coordinates all the phone calls and all
the stuff and all this because y'all
don't because what you're doing is hey
you're getting your self-esteem from
being the hero and that's a dangerous
place to be the second thing is is
you're trying to control the behaviors
of a whole bunch of different adults and
it's exhausting and it doesn't work
yes and they all end up presenting you
and it's not even you that did it did it
but they resent you
right
yeah oh God Christine's calling again oh
great Christine gonna be asking us for
just quit and I would use that language
hey family I'm resigning from this this
uh crisis responder that's not my job my
job is to be your daughter my doc my job
is to be uh her sister
those are my two jobs that's what I'm
going to do I'm gonna do them really
really well
and uh then I'm gonna move on from there
and you're gonna have to heal from hero
complex because you can't save all these
adults the only person on planet Earth
you can control unfortunately is you
let's make sure you're well and you're
whole
and we're down from the position of
judgment we're not at at we are with
and then when she's ready she'll know
you're safe
and that's the worst I'm so so sorry
don't quit fighting for
don't quit fighting for but don't lose
yourself in the process